the honourable member for barry
innesville
thank you mr speaker the eyes of the
nation are upon us tonight earlier today
the prime minister signaled as did a
member of his back bench that tonight's
vote is a confidence vote convention
requires that the prime minister to
publicly declare a confidence vote of
this nature as such following convention
my question for the government house
leader
is the vote tonight a confidence vote
and if the vote
will the prime minister plunge us into
an election
the honourable government house leader
mr speaker i appreciate the debate but
it's time to vote
[Applause]
the question is the following one
mr menoccino seconded by mr trudeau
moved
that pursuant to section 58 of the
emergencies act this house confirmed the
declaration of a public order emergency
proclaimed on february 14 2022.
the period of demonetized
all those in favor of the motion will
please draw us mr blair mr gabra mr
gabriel
ms grow escrow
mr mcginty mr mcginty mr scarpalegia
miss cara there's cara mr van dyke
mr mckinnon get to know
[Music]
mr fergus mr ferguson mr ananda sangari
miss dylan
mr essaci mr assassin
mr nagri
mr neckface mr c do brampton east
mrs suds mrs
mr fragiscaro
mr maloney mr maloney mr schiffke mr
schiffke mr sorbara mr
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
all those opposed to the motion will
please rise
ms finley
[Music]
ms dan show
mr michaelian minton west mr mccauley
edmonton west mr schmale
mr tucker mr tucker mr baldinelli mr
baldwin mr lloyd mr lloyd mr lawrence mr
duncan storm and anderson gary mr duncan
dundas southam gary mr kimmich
mr culkins republicans mr upal
mr muller mr miller mr hsn mr hsn mr lob
mr love mr perkins mr perkins
mrs gallant this is
mr reed mr reed mr caputo mr caputo miss
ferrari
mr martel mr martinez mr gould
mr steinle mr sterling ms rood that's
rude my name is
miss lewis haldeman norfolk this is
louis norfolk
mrs block this is brooke mr veerson mr
beerson mr williamson mr whatever mr
maguire mr mcguire mr abulteve
mr arnold arnold
mr cooper mr cooper
mr kelly mr kelly mr kitchen mr kitchen
mrs tubbs this is stubbs
mr shields mr shields mr wall
mr wong mr webber mr webber mr motz mr
motz mr lew mr mr bragdon mr bragan
mr morrison mr morrison mr patzer
mr soroka mr
mr
mr brock mr brock mr muse mr muse mrs
roberts this is robert mr barrett mr
barrett mr pauliev peter
[Applause]
[Applause]
mr
[Music]
the house will now wait for the
electronic voting period to end before
resuming its proceedings
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
to
i wish you informed the house that the
electronic voting period has ended
i will invite members who encounter
technical difficulties to identify
themselves if members were not able to
vote due to technical difficulties they
may now use the raise hand function and
the chair will recognize them
ms zerowitz
mr speaker my app has asked me to
confirm that i have voted and i vote yay
your your vote has been uh cast as yes
mr president
[Music]
mr morris
mr speaker i had issues with the app i
will be voting nay contrera
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
but i'm wagonthought
yes thank you speaker i would like to
confirm that i voted nay
[Music]
paul
called against colt
mr hoback
mr speaker to confirm that i voted no
mr
mr fast
mr speaker i vote no
mr fast
against colt
mr mclean
thank you mr speaker i just want to make
sure you know that i vote no to this
motion
mr mclean
against colt
mr
zing i vote for the motion
[Music]
mr singh for poor
miss thomas
mr speaker i want to confirm that my
vote is no
mrs thomas against colt
miss goodridge
thank you mr speaker i would like to
confirm that my vote is no
it is confirmed
mr genius
thank you mr chair i want to confirm
that my vote was cast as a nay
it is written it is registered
mr reticop
thank you mr speaker i just too want to
confirm that my vote was cast as a
dignity
you have always registered his name mr
stewart
mr stewart
okay maybe come real well don't go back
uh
ms kwon
thank you mr speaker my voting app was
not working and i vote yes
is kwanpoor
ms gray
mr speaker i vote no
mr speaker i'd like to confirm that my
vote was a nay
your phone was registered his name
mr viss mr speaker i'm
confirmed that my vote was nay
it's confirmed at nay mr stewart
can you hear me
go for it
can you hear me now
in any way
thank you
anybody else
okay we'll compile a vote
yes poor 185
saul
these call 151
i declare the motion carried
the honorable leader of the official
opposition
and appointed speaker
i rise to file with you pursuant to
section 59 of the emergencies act a
motion to revoke the prime minister's
emergency declaration that was
proclaimed last week
[Applause]
is signed by more than 20 members of the
conservative party
the government house leader
mr speaker
uh
mr speaker as you are aware the there
was a house order the house would
adjourn after the vote
[Music]
we were waiting for two points of order
at this time
hold on i'll let her finish and then
we'll finish up the matter at the next
week
i say this to all canadians that
conservatives will continue to use every
tool at our disposal to end the prime
minister's
point of order mr speaker
this is not a point of order mr speaker
mr speaker i i would just like to take
the time to thank the staff who stayed
over the course of the weekend the
clerks the house administration uh it
has been a long hour this has been a
historic debate but i think we should
thank all the people who serve this
place for their incredible service thank
you mr speaker
coming
come
mark